hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of CET V we are graciously
hosted by the cloud and air team they
run these amazing technical webinars
every Tuesday so make sure you sure you
continue to tune in and watch those
today I'm super excited because we have
two of the hottest topics in cloud big
data and machine learning and to help me
with that I have one of the amazing
Google cloud product managers Abhishek
with me
Abhishek what you might introduce
yourself Thank You Nick hi everyone I'm
Abhishek Asha and I'm the product
manager and very delighted to be here
and talk to you about bigquery ml
awesome
yeah so Big Data machine learning for
any of you out there who are playing
buzzword bingo now's your time to bring
out those scratch cards because I think
that we'll be highlighting some pretty
exciting stuff going through so so in
order to start talking about bigquery ml
I think we should at least first cover
what bigquery is so for any of you who
are unaware of what bigquery is bigquery
is our fully managed enterprise data
warehouse solution that essentially
provides enterprise features and
functionality for those real-time sequel
queries that I need to run it's it's
pretty unique because it has goals
unique back-end architecture of
separating compute and storage so that
as you scale up your compute environment
as you scale up your storage environment
basically everything is completely
seamless to you all you see as the end
user is you upload data to bigquery you
hit the giant big red button that says
run query and you get some results and
the other amazing thing is that because
it's fully managed Google takes care of
your encryption takes care of the
reliability availability all that stuff
all that typical heartache and heavy
weights with managing clusters all that
kind of stuff so we take that burden off
of our users so Abhishek since we're
gonna be talking about bigquery ml why
are those two topics related why why big
data plus machine learning there are two
topics are related because if you think
about where the world the industry is
going there used to be a lot of
historical analysis of data okay if you
look at the journey of analytics on data
in the data warehouse
everyone used to clean the data
processor to build dashboards and
present to executives and make decisions
based on those sure but all these
decisions were based on historical
trends as we see the advent of machine
learning and machine learning at the
scale to work on terabytes of data all
these decisions could be made in a
predictive way so rather than using
somebody's wisdom on what's going to
happen tomorrow you could actually have
machine learning applied to every
decision that gets taken and the way we
see this manifesting is just like
bigquery made made it very very easy to
go from having to manage your clusters
and the node size and the performance to
only thinking about analysis and writing
sequel to do the analysis yeah we
believe machine learning should be the
same way you should not have to think
about the underlying infrastructure ok
how many nodes do I need to provision to
build a machine learning model or do I
need to split my data into training and
tests yes you always should so what if
we automated all of these and build the
machine learning foundations where the
data is which in our case is bigquery
awesome yeah that's exciting stuff yep
yeah so I'm a little bit curious how
have customers previously use bigquery
plus machine learning in the past so if
you think about a typical process since
it's really hard to do machine learning
where the data is yeah the first step is
people end up exporting data to an
object store ok and from there if you
are a data analyst you would take a
small sample to sheets do a linear
regression you have an idea to improve
the model you go back export more data
and do it all over the game if you
happen to be a data scientist you can
take your favorite Python framework and
convert the data into frames that that
framework takes
build your model to improve you go back
and get more data so that's the process
that you follow and it takes hours and
days for each situation just because of
the backend work that's needed yeah I
can see an issue just not only for time
because it takes time to obviously
export the data from bigquery important
to GCS or whatever your framework is but
also you're starting kind of a bad trend
of creating data silos you have multiple
data sources that you have to manage if
you're updating your bigquery data set
in real time now you have to somehow get
those over to the GCS buckets so I can
definitely see it as a big challenge
don't how are we how are we kind of
running into those issues and how we're
dealing with this and actually to those
point it's actually okay to have silos
in GCS we have actually we have seen
data scientists having silos on their
laptops okay people didn't want a laptop
fine and then they share with each other
using email and SCP so that's the extent
of the silos that are being created with
the current processes okay and so these
challenges how are they typically
affecting companies yes so the two
challenges we see one most companies do
not hire enough data scientists and it's
not that they do not want to if you just
go a simple search on LinkedIn you'll
find that there are maybe up to a
million data scientists okay and if you
think how many of those million can
actually go ahead and write here
best-in-class noodle Network that number
is probably 1/10 of that yeah if you if
you start thinking I need to do
reinforcement learning that's probably
thousands of people so the first problem
is if you are going to have so few data
scientists there is no way that you can
apply machine learning to more than two
three four percent of the business
problems that you deal with the second
problem is as I walked through the
process it takes a gird six to eight
hours in just setting up the
infrastructure even if you know what
you're doing
to build your first model so equations
actually take a lot of time
because you have to set a five-tool set
of data transfer you have to set up
conversion of data from one format to
another and that's actually a big big
productivity inhibitor yeah that make
sense
and that's what we are trying to fix so
we launched a bigquery ml in beta in
July at our conference in San Francisco
and it allows you anyone who knows
sequel to do machine learning just using
sequel without having to learn Python R
and with in bigquery so you do not have
to move the data out either and that's
what bigquery ml is it is simply machine
learning using sequel in bigquery mm-hmm
and it actually makes ml accessible for
all audiences yeah that's a good point
so in Google Cloud we have kind of
different paradigms of machine learning
so on one side of the spectrum you have
the ml API is you have Auto ml on the
other side of the spectrum you have full
customization with the cloud machine
learning engine and so it seems like
this is a good middle ground because
machine learning is is incredibly
transformational across all of our
customers I mean I've seen it seen and
heard some really incredible stories and
so I feel like what we're doing as as
Google is empowering all sorts of users
whether you're a developer a back engine
and back-end engineer sre sequel
developer all these kind of groups and
users now have the power to bring
machine learning to whatever it is that
they touch yeah exactly yeah exactly so
if you think about what's needed to have
machine learning be pervasive across the
organization we believe democratization
is what's needed you need to build tools
for people and have them use machine
learning where they are you you cannot
expect that your developers to data
analyst to data scientist all of them
will pick a Python and R and they all
will be a data scientist rather than
doing that we believe we need to provide
tools so anyone can build a machine
learning model and bigquery ml
specifically targets the gap we
you have these data analysts who
understand your domain who understand
the data but they do not have the tools
to build a mod so we have tensorflow
for data scientists to build the state
of the art model we have Auto ml cloud
ml api's so developers can just call an
API on standard problems like object
detection but there's a big gap in terms
of you have your custom data custom
business problems data analysts are the
only ones who understand it deeply and
they can now start using machine
learning using bigquery ml that's
awesome
very exciting so how does it really work
in an end picture how does it how does
it work further end users yes sir if you
think about an end user the end user can
now just log into the data warehouse or
go to a notebook or wherever they are
writing sequel stain sequel to build a
machine learning model stain sequel to
train the model with in bigquery so you
actually bring ml to the data rather
than taking data to ml okay time X and
finally I'll show you in the demo just
with a couple lines of sequel which is
machine learning specific you can build
a model so you do not have to worry
about hyper parameter tuning basic
feature transformations which are needed
for almost every machine learning model
you back yeah and I'm curious what kind
of customers are using BQ or bigquery ml
and do you have any example use cases
that you can share yeah definitely so we
usually run a private alpha before we
launch a beta and we had a very
successful alpha these are some of the
public references who agreed to share
their use case I'll start with first
newspapers so media companies are
usually spending a lot of effort on
reducing churn and in their case they
wanted to start doing predictive churn
modeling to do much marketing campaigns
okay to people who are more likely to
churn as an exemption to do that they
I started working with big query ml they
managed to write the first term
prediction model within a day that's
awesome that's kind of the model
actually combined data from six
different sources and since this was
sequel they were able to do the join
staying in the sequel platform and post
that join they just built a model in BQ
ml and then they set up a pipeline using
cloud Composer to do the training and do
predictions and to have a dashboard that
guides to marketing campaigns and they
managed to finish the whole process
within a couple of sprints so that's
what they got by using bigquery ml 20th
Century Fox they actually introduced a
product in our keynote demo they have a
lot of business decisions that they make
on top of the recommendation system they
have which is actually a pretty
state-of-the-art tensorflow
recommendation system but the business
decisions are things like okay which
audiences should be marketed which
movies should be green light and having
those actually takes up a lot of data
scientist time which like everyone else
they don't have a lot of sure so they
use machine learning in bigquery to
build classification models to decide
which audiences are more likely to watch
an upcoming movie and market to them
accordingly okay similarly there are
other companies who have used it for a
variety of different use cases where
they had a lot of data in bigquery but
they did not want to go through the
process of exporting it and setting up
multiple tools and they did not have
enough data scientists to have working
on every problem yeah doctor need to
address yeah
so the trend I'm hearing is not enough
resources in terms of people analysts
data scientists to crunch through
massive amounts of data and that data is
is oftentimes complex but not only that
it's spread across multiple datasets
multiple tables and we're allowing them
to perform joins who combined this data
into one machine learning model that
gets built
that's pretty exciting that's cool yep
okay and that's what they all are doing
cool and I hear that you have a demo for
us so I'm definitely excited to see this
in action so what is this demo going to
be walking through and and let's get to
it
yep so if you imagine a typical scenario
which is you have data about your
website analytics coming in which is
Google Analytics 360 and if you have say
revenue data coming in a lot of our
customers actually join across the tube
to make marketing decisions true but the
typical output of this join as I
mentioned earlier is just a chart on the
dashboard what bigquery ml allows you to
do is to actually build a machine
learning model to do predictions and
since this is part of the bigquery API
you can actually use these predictions
to both connect to your action systems
which in this case could be email
marketing or ads and to directly add it
to the dashboard of your choice because
bigquery works with almost all bi
platforms that are out there
yep yeah so you can do both because this
is already in the bigquery API okay and
our customers already have the set up of
downstream systems and it makes it very
easy to add machine learning to it
fantastic and you go to the specific
demo scenario what we did is we have
public data set from a Google
merchandise store that's in bigquery you
can actually go browse it and if you are
a marketer at any online if you sell
anything on your website what you want
to do is you want to track visitors to
your website and we market to them to
have them come back and purchase yeah
this is a fairly standard problem the
issue is that for the Google merchandise
store data we see 0.7 percent of the
people actually come came back and
purchased ok now if we have a marketer
and you know less than 1% are going to
come back and purchase if you blanket
market to all of them it's highly
inefficient and it's not going to lead
to as good a conversion
so what if you could predict who's going
to come back and purchase into stock and
that's what the demo is and I will other
reaction okay so this is the new
bigquery UI that we recently launched
and you can see I'll make it bigger that
this is a sequel statement that's
getting data from okay the public data
set yep
and we have data from one year so we
take nine months of data for training
hmm
and we'll keep the last three months to
test to show you how the model data okay
it's a verify that's actually working
okay and what we want to predict is if
somebody will come back and purchase
sure so all we need to do for that is
say if someone visited and there was a
transaction and this wasn't the first
visit then it's a bill by later is true
okay and that's what we'll try to
predict we select some usual columns
like where did the person come from how
many pages did the person view which
country which we medium which operating
system and just throw them in as
features okay and see what happens so
the machine learning models can be built
off of these features that you specify
exact statement okay so yeah make sense
then the only machine learning we need
to do is on top of the Select statement
that ever even knows how to write you
just say create model you give it a name
we are predicting which is the labels if
someone will come back and purchase and
this is a classification model so we use
logistic regression for this okay and
question on that so for this use case
we're specifying a logistical regression
but what are the other classification
models that are supported we have
started simple and most useful with
linear regression and logistic
regression okay
forecasting and classification but to
your point we are going to add a lot
more models for different use cases
pretty soon and we want to get to a
point where you don't even need to
decide which model to use oh oh can you
can decide it for you so we can use
machine learning to then pick the
accurate machine where anymore exactly
exactly
like Inception we there was a survey by
goggle last year that actually showed
65% of the models Whitten by data
scientists are still digesting ization
hmm ok that's pretty much so so logistic
regression actually does capture most of
the use cases which are out there ok and
that's what we have seen with customers
so all I need to do is execute this
query this will take about three minutes
to build on 22 gigs of data ok but what
we did was we went from there to test on
the last three months of data because we
knew who came back and purchased sure we
scored the list based on the model
there's a function called ml dot product
ok and then we just plotted that list
according to the score according to the
likelihood of them coming back and
purchased and what we found was that if
as a marketer you only market it to the
top six percent six point five percent
of them actually came back in purchased
oh that's a lot better than the zero
point seven percent exactly yeah okay
sessions are actually fairly accurate
mm-hmm okay and more than that as a
marketer you are concerned about we call
you actually still would capture 50
percent of the returned buyers
Wow so we're just saying create model
and giving it a name yeah you actually
have a model that's this good if you
want to just look at some of the
evaluation curves which we plotted based
on the data from our model these
actually look really good yeah yeah
that's fantastic if you showed it to a
data scientist I'm pretty sure they are
going to approve this model with
pretty much two lines of code I mean
exactly you have the standard sequel
statement and they just field model on
top of it yes exactly that's impressive
very cool and and I think we should
highlight on one specific thing oh sorry
actually go back I think we should
highlight one specific thing was that
that you built this model I mean with
two lines of code and this is pretty
advanced I mean you have quite a few
capabilities so would you mind touching
on that yeah definitely so if you think
about it this model did not ask you to
set up an infrastructure to Train yep we
leverage bigquery and we just created as
many processes as as needed to build
this model for you and this is going to
work on the petabyte of training data if
that's your use case because you never
have to think about the infrastructure
and bigquery today can query a petabyte
fairly easily yeah
secondly there's a hyper parameter for
this called learning rate the auto-tuned
it we know that you should not be
overfitting so if your data is large
enough we automatically split it into
training and test how can we do a random
80/20 split which is the most common
numeric features should never be put it
put in as is so we standardized all of
them and I'm curious about that why
shouldn't we be using numeric features
like dates and stuff like that there's a
Whitney Mary creatures if they're scale
is fairly different across two features
then one starts dominating over the
other next say one of the feature is
weights in pounds and one of the
features ends up being distance and the
distance is up to two miles or two
kilometres suddenly your weight will be
a dominant feature gotcha so you don't
want that to affect similarly if one
person builds some model using weights
in kilograms and one in pounds your
model will start looking at weight okay
so so you want to standardize your
numeric features and models work with
numbers so let's say you have strength
features like categories or boolean so
categories you cannot just feed in XYZ
we automatically one-hot encode them to
convert them to numbers so these are
some of the basic things that we do
which enable getting to such a good
model so fast and if you are an advanced
user you know more machine learning you
can use l1 l2 regularization you can
select how to split your training and
test data so if you wanted a date based
split or if you wanted a different it
split than 80/20 you can specify all
those and finally you can set your own
learning rate as well the philosophy
that we have is everything that gets to
a better model is going to be automated
and things that allow the power users to
get to a better model will provide them
as options and that's what we are doing
so you can always just write two lines
of sequel and get to a really good model
that's fantastic and so so we've
obviously showed how simple it can be
but how about some of the more complex
features some of the more complex
aspects of the machine learning what do
we support from from that perspective so
we support creation and prediction using
the model from standard sequel you can
use UDF's within we are starting with
two types of machine learning models
will add more over time but to evaluate
how the model date we actually have
evaluation functions which give you a
GoSee curve if it's logistic regression
or specific stats for linear regression
we allow you to inspect the weights to
see how much of feature impacted the
prediction and finally we have table
valued functions so you can also analyze
your features to see how they were
distributed so that's something you
that's very useful doing feature
engineering yeah yeah I know that can be
a little bit complex and and involved
especially from the tensorflow side so
that seems like we simplify this but
still give you the ability to kind of do
some tuning yes now that that's cool
exactly and let's see if the
model finished yeah so it did finish
okay in three minutes in 12 seconds and
if we just go to the model what you see
is some basic model details when they
were built what type it is what the last
type was mmm
we use a creative gradient descent so it
shows you what different parameters were
chosen okay and if you look at the
starts it will show you the lost arts
for training and evaluation data and a
learning rate and how much time it took
model schema shows you the different
fields we used as features okay and
their types so these are the ones we had
in the Select statement and we are going
to add more charts here so you can start
looking at curves and precision we call
etc Oh awesome what's any UI in did you
watch that cool that's gonna shock
thankful now you can actually look at it
in data studio directly off of bigquery
oh okay so it's it so we got a model
built on 22 gates of data took three
minutes seeding lines of code no machine
learn and ya know machine learning
experience required cool and I think one
thing that that we kind of touched on
that we should emphasize is bigquery is
one piece of the entire Google cloud
kind of data pipeline strategy so before
data gets into bigquery you can perform
ETL maybe through data flow you mention
cloud composer so you can compose like
how things are be excuse me being run in
terms of like jobs and wood job start
when they end et cetera and then finally
the the data that's being stored in
bigquery is typically in a tabular
format so lots of rows lots of columns
and a normal human being might not be
quite as good at actually plotting those
data points out if you have thousands
hundreds of thousands of rows who knows
and so the the amazing thing is that
bigquery is already integrated into
quite a few business intelligence
dashboards so this data can already be
plugged into sources like data studio
tab
look or etc in fact one of the really
awesome use cases that I recently read
is from tableau where they took some of
the public data that's out there on home
prices in Seattle and they ran a
bigquery
machine learning model against it and
identified what would a home cost if you
want two bedrooms three bedrooms if you
want that fancy waterfront view or or in
town square footage of the house I mean
it's it's pretty transformational and
it's exciting that you can build
something that's quite comprehensive
from just a couple lines of code
spending a couple minutes it's pretty
exciting so yep that's really cool and
yeah yeah so as a user if you log in to
their dashboard you can manually type in
these fields okay and it will use
bigquery ml in the background to get you
the predicted prices so it's fairly
interactive and that's what you need to
use a BI platform for yes anyways
exactly
exactly how to drill down from the
massive amounts of data into something a
little bit more meaningful cool and I
also hear that looker has some specific
integrations with bigquery ml so maybe
we can touch on those - yeah definitely
so looker we have a deep partnership
word where they have integrated by query
ml to their markup language called look
ml and you can actually create a model
string with the looker okay without
actually having to go and write sequel
oh okay without getting into the query
exact sequel statement yes
oh and on top of that some of the
evaluation charts I showed they built
some templates for those what they call
local looker blocks and they have
operationalized the whole lemon worth
flow so local customers can actually
start using the query ml through their
native integrations as well and that
that's where we are headed with other BI
platforms as well nice yeah it's awesome
that everyone it's kind of adopting this
as a feature and pushing out to all
their customers - yes because everyone
realizes that machine learning is the
future yeah I think so and if we
actually have talked to a lot of data
analysts and they all are taking courses
on Coursera and they're all
reading up and we believe the more tools
we can provide to make the transition
easier the better it is and the better
the perforation of machine learning will
be across the enterprises and if you
just think about your industry and think
about some of the business problems
there are actually a lot of them which
could be machine learning based and what
we have seen is if you take retail and
if you say I can optimize inventory in a
productive way I can predict which item
is going to be needed in which region in
what quantity that actually you would
think that it's only an efficiency play
but more than that it's actually a
customer satisfaction play as well okay
okay because now your customers in a
particular reason or region are not
going to see longer shipping times
they're not going to see stock-outs yeah
so there are a lot of operational supply
chain marketing forecasting problems we
are just drawing a straight line from my
store eagle trend is actually fairly
inefficient so if you could use machine
learning for each of those and some of
our users are actually working with that
data day-in day-out then that's going to
have a great impact on the business
metrics themselves mm-hmm cool
so I think it's important to also try to
touch on since this is a brand new
component of bigquery how to start
getting started with it how to get your
hands on it the exciting thing is that
bigquery ml is available today in beta
and so you can start using it today
start building your own models some
great resources for getting trained
obviously watching this webinar helps
but it doesn't get you completely there
so there's some fantastic blogs that are
out there a couple particularly from
Googler named lack he has written some
fantastic blogs about how to predict
flight times I think there's another one
about predict predicting natality data
sets which are really awesome so if you
google search Lac bigquery
m/l you'll find probably like three or
four blogs on that specific subject so I
definitely give that a read secondly is
there are courses already out there on
big query ml and actually breaks down
some of the necessary components around
big query Big Data machine learning the
concepts behind machine learning because
while we've made it pretty simple for
our users it's still important to
understand how the machine learning
actually works in the backend the tip
different types of algorithms stuff like
that and there's already a course on
that on Coursera com so they're data
insights on course which is pretty
phenomenal I've gone through that myself
and then obviously you start getting
your hands on big query ml start using
it and if there's any feedback that you
have go ahead and flood this this email
address here the B qml - feedback at
Google comm that you're going to get
quite a few requests for feature
enhancements and stuff like that it's
it's exciting that we can take some of
those the feedback from the community
and start building out it building it
out into actual products and stuff and
that's pretty much how bigquery ml
started so that's really exciting
yep cool and what we have seen is if you
know sequel whether you use bigquery or
lard or not mm-hm
we have public datasets you can go to
the platform get familiar with in a few
hours and you can actually write your
first model within another two hours
oh you if you know it it's 15 minutes to
write your first model you know even if
you don't you go to a documentation in
follower tutorial and within an hour or
two you'll have your first machine
learning model so that's going to be so
exciting with the first time I did it
when I plotted the results I was super
excited to see how close it was to the
predictions then I went back and tweak
the features and it kept on getting
better and better without me having to
go learn Python which is a tall task or
understanding all the linear algebra
requirements that are in that the
algorithms for predict image exactly
that's cool that's very cool awesome
well I was like I'm super grateful that
you were able to join us with this we're
gonna cut over to some of the questions
that you guys have been asking live so
give us one minute and then we'll be
back to address your questions on camera
I'm sure there's gonna be a lot of stuff
about a big query ml so glad to have you
help answer those questions for us you
like it
you
hey everyone and welcome back thank you
all the questions that you've been
submitting throughout the course of this
webinar we have five really awesome
questions I'm glad that you're here so
that you can answer them for me
so I guess jumpy right into it does my
data need to be in bigquery to use
bigquery ml I'm thinking like federated
queries that kind of aspect is the data
actually have to be in bigquery ml or
bigquery or can it be external yeah you
are right we can Fred rate from GCS
today okay so your data could be in GCS
or bigquery the whole idea of bigquery
ml is that you bring ml to the data and
you devilish the bigquery is processing
power so your data for this to work has
to be in bigquery or if it's in GCS we
can Fred v8 or we can just get it in and
use bigquery llaman man that makes it
pretty powerful because you can query
across multiple sources of data
therefore kind of eliminating that that
the aspect of having different data
silos exactly cool cool ok on to the
second question how can we use bigquery
ml on unstructured data it depends on
the unstructured data what the data is
if you think about unstructured as short
strings mm-hmm say category of a user
etcetera we one hot and code them and
you can use it directly ok if you start
thinking unstructured data as say pages
and paragraphs and phrases sure in that
case that data needs to be converted to
a number for bigquery ml to use and to
convert to that number a typical process
is to convert it into some kind of an
embedding like an example could be you
have a document and you use what to back
to convert it to in the vector and
embedding yeah that may that knows which
phases are similar to which phases and
then you can take those two points and
you know that closer points are similar
and then you can feed those in to
bigquery ml as a feature so to work with
unstructured data that's a lot of text
you'll have to convert them into some
embedding and the embedding could be a
traditional NLP technique like bag of
words or tf-idf
all it could be something very advanced
like word to back doctor back well you
could also call Auto ml API or cloud ml
API yeah
convert it into some structured
semantics like which are the entities
and which what's the sentiment and use
those in bigquery ml as is yeah that's
an excellent point because bigquery ml
is not just or is not the only machine
learning platform within Google so if
you want to send some unstructured
images send them to the vision API
videos to the intelligence API and you
can get structured responses like you
said sentiment maybe identify the nouns
verbs the content of images and you can
place those in your bigquery data set
and then query them with bigquery ml
that's all that kind of ties everything
together yeah and as you think about
some of the more advanced applications
like they found to do stock predictions
better you should also get some news yes
suddenly you can start seeing once you
go past just using structured data how
easily you can start getting in the
unstructured data to move your model
cool awesome very cool
okay so jump in to the third question
how do I retrain the model with new data
that's good one and that's actually how
you would put it into production okay
what we see is depending on your use
case depending on how quickly your
inherent data changes customers between
it anyway from once a day to once a
quarter
so you you have to decide what the right
frequency is and since this is entirely
in sequel through the bigquery API you
would use a shed you laying platform
like we have composer okay which is
based on open source air flow yes yeah
that could just call you a create model
query point it to the new data which
could be written as a view and just
retrain it at the frequency that you
chose okay
and then it waits for the model to be
built since you are calling it from the
composer API and once it's built you
start using it for productions okay that
seems
simple cool okay number four can I
export a big query ml model for online
predictions yes so exporting as a
function is not provided out of the gate
okay but we do provide ml dot weights
which you can use for feature inspection
so you can take the weights of the model
and you can export it to you online
infrastructure once the model that way
okay so ml dot weights is the way to
export a model today I can use it for
online predictions and talking about
that Lac actually wrote a blog on this
particular problem as well and in that
blog he walks to step by step on how you
would set it up okay cool
and then final question how does
bigquery ml pricing work and I'm
thinking in terms of like the slot usage
and and other aspects yes so bigquery ml
is we have preview pricing right now
since it's in beta and bigquery has two
types of crisis structure one is flat
rate where you buy a set number of slots
which are processing units and on demand
will you pay for the data that you query
so for flat rate during the preview
pricing we are going to include it with
the current slots okay so if you are
already on flat rate you use the same
slots for bigquery mmm okay and then you
can mix and match your other jobs with
ml jobs or to get to a really good
utilization for on-demand a prediction
or evaluation is like a standard query
so that's five dollars a terabyte okay
for model creation during the preview we
are charging five dollars a gigabyte and
the reason is one even though it's two
lines of sequel it's actually a lot of
work underneath sure to get to a really
good model yeah and secondly it's taking
away a good six to eight hours of
infrastructure setup yeah and that's the
value that this is providing yeah okay
that makes perfect sense
cool well fantastic I'm glad you were
able to get through all those questions
so I wish I could thank you so much for
joining us I'm really thrilled to have
you here and for all of our viewers out
there thank you for joining the session
on the bigquery ml up next we have a
session around Google slides tips and
tricks so you'll definitely want to
stick around for that and until next
time I guess I'll we'll see you later
thank you if there's a pleasure thank
you thank you